It took me forever but I figured out what
this newspaper says and what implications
it has for the story.
Stick around to the end of this video if you
want to see it.
In 2017 I made one of the first movie Things
You Missed episodes on It: Chapter One.
Here’s what I said at the end.
“...and when the trailer for Chapter 2 drops
you can count on a Things You Missed episode
from me.”
And today that trailer did drop, so here’s
me keeping my promise, just as the Losers
Club keeps their promise to return to Derry,
should It rise again.
The trailer begins with Beverly going back
to her father’s old apartment.
She hasn’t talked to him since moving to
Chicago years ago, and it would probably be
a bit awkward, considering she smashed his
head open the last time they saw each other
in 1989.
When she arrives she discovers her father
is no longer there, instead there’s this
old woman named Mrs. Kersh.
Beverly thinks that she may have misread the
name on the door, somehow confusing her own
last name Marsh, with Kersh.
But in the opening shot of the trailer it
clearly says: Marsh.
Bev finds the postcard given to her by Ben
27 years ago while Mrs. Kersh is making tea,
and if you pay attention to Beverly’s arms,
they are covered in bruises.
In the novel, Bev has an abusive husband named
Tom, who she flees from to come to Derry.
She also has something hanging around her
neck.
I’m not sure what it is, but it reminds
me of the key she wore as a child.
We never see what it’s for in the first
movie.
Mrs. Kersh’s shirt is covered in birds,
and birds can be seen throughout her apartment,
which could be a clue about her true nature.
It’s not really mentioned in Chapter 1,
but birds play a major part in the novel,
where Mike first encounters It in the form
of a giant bird that attacks him, and Stan
would later use his vast knowledge of birds
to determine that It’s bird form is not
real, which weakens it.
As Beverly looks around the apartment at the
photos, Mrs. Kersh peeks out and looks at
her, all naked and creepy like woman from
The Visit.
The photo shows Pennywise in his human form,
Bob Grey, another detail that wasn’t a part
of the first film.
Before she attacks, Mrs. Kersh asks the following
question:
“What about you?
Are you still his little girl Beverly?
Are you!?”
This is probably a reference to Beverly’s
fear of her father, and the fact that It takes
the shape of her dad temporarily during the
final battle in Chapter 1.
"Hey Bevvy.
Are you still my little girl?
AGHHH!!"
Then we finally get our reveal shot of some
more members of the Losers Club including
Mike, Richie, Bill, Beverly and Ben.
Eddie doesn't show up until later in the trailer.
They see themselves as kids in the reflection
of this window, one of the many ways they
become more childlike when they return to
Derry, much like how Bill gets his stutter
back in the book, and the scars they cut into
their hands to make the promise reappear when
they find out It’s back.
They are also in front of an ice cream shop.
There is a scene where they get ice cream
in the book after Ben stands up for Beverly
against this kid named Bradley Donovan.
Hopefully the childhood flashbacks in It Chapter
2 are going to fill in some of the events
that took place that summer that they didn’t
have room for in the first movie, as opposed
to the flashbacks just being used to reiterate
stuff.
That looks to be the case because this shot
of them riding bikes is a completely different
day than anything that happens in the first
one; I’ve never seen Richie wearing this
zombie hand shirt before.
One such flashback could be hinted at with
this scene of Richie at City Center.
In the first one, this is where we learn that
Richie is afraid of clowns.
This Paul Bunyan statue is shown, but doesn’t
do anything in the movie.
In the book, Richie goes there by himself
one day and the statue comes to life and attacks
him, so maybe that’s a scene we’ll get
to see in a flashback.
There are other locations that they return
to from the first movie, like the hill leading
to the Barrens and this sewer pipe where they
first met Ben, it looks like the water is
higher now.
The town is once again littered with missing
child posters as it was in 1989, I found it
interesting that it’s not the busy town
it once was, the streets are empty.
It took me a while to decipher what this blurry
Daily Derry newspaper headline said, but I’ve
come to the conclusion that it says: “Body
found in Barrens”.
This must be Dennis Torio, a boy who is murdered
in the novel and police find Georgie’s picture
at the crime scene.
Speaking of which, it looks like the ghost
of Georgie is not done haunting Bill.
This Chinese restaurant is called the Oriental
Jade, and this is where they meet up for the
first time in 27 years.
I noticed that the gong in the background
here is moving, and I can just see Richie
slamming the gong to commence their meeting,
and disturbing all the other diners.
OK, this shot shows thousands of balloons
under a bridge, one for every comment that
tells me I look like Shaggy.
No, but what this really is, is the event
that sets the new cycle of It into motion.
It starts at a festival celebrating Derry.
I’m guessing that’s what this is.
Three drunk guys come to harass a gay couple
and one of them gets pushed off of a bridge
where Pennywise is waiting, and bites the
guy’s arm off, before thousands of red,
“I love Derry” balloons rise up and hit
the bottom of the bridge.
For this shot, I’m not going to go into
it because I don’t want some viewer to get
mad about spoilers and then some to my house
and bite my ear off or something, but if you
want a clue, I’ll just say to read Chapter
21 in the book, I think that’s what we’re
seeing here.
I will however talk about this other shot
where we see the white clown gloves grabbing
this little ball of light.
When I talked about the first movie, I theorized
that these little lights that Beverly sees
down the throat of It are an interpretation
of the deadlights, the true form of It.
And I think that’s what we’re seeing again
here, Pennywise using the deadlights to hypnotize
this girl.
The little girl with the bruise on her face
can be seen wandering under the bleachers
during some kind of sporting event.
My guess is that this is Dawn Roy, a 13 year
old girl found dead in McCairn Park.
Mike tells everyone about the recent pattern
of dead or missing children at lunch at the
Chinese restaurant and this is one of the
victims that he mentions.
If you need a refresher on the Things You
Missed from the first movie, click the video
on the left.
I’m planning a whole slate of videos about
It: Chapter 2 from now until the movie released
in September, so make sure you subscribe to
CZsWorld for new horrors every week, ring
that deathbell for notifications and I’ll
see you in the next one.
Assuming we allllll float.